one of the many graveyards for old
retired ships found along the Nigerian
coast in the middle of this shipping
lane the bridge of a sunken ship sticks
out of the water and weighing down on it
is another abundant vessel on its way to
the bottom operators say the shipping
routes here keep getting shallower and
narrower and that's a problem for not
only sailors but also the economies of
countries in the region Russia produces
lots the best you're not going to bring
your ships into uncharted waters or
whether you have wrecks the loss is
caused by the presence of these abundant
ships in the Gulf of Guinea continue to
mount nobody's going to invest in any
parts in any industry
so secure those specifics
money you can replace structural in
place with lives you incarnate maritime
officials acknowledge the enormity of
the problem and have warned anyone
against dumping ships in the area
published notifying those that have
their vessels along navigation routes or
abandoned in areas our journey in
evolutionary routes to remove the
routine assess impeded the ones that
requires urgent attention those ones are
being removed right now so speak rich in
oil and fish resources the Gulf of
Guinea attracts heavy shipping traffic
but maritime experts say that could
change unless the authorities top their
waterways from becoming dumping grounds
these shipwrecks have laid here for many
years
the Nigerian maritime administration and
Safety Agency said recently they've
removed some but those are few of the
many of the abandoned ship that litter
the waterways of the Gulf of Guinea and
as traffic increases so do the risks
they pose to ships and humans but what
some consider a problem others see an
opportunity like these crab dealers who
strip the old ships of what metals they
can get government agencies in charge of
maritime safety in the region need money
without adequate funding these wrecks
will be here for some time along with
the dangers they pose ahamed Idris al
Jazeera Lagos Nigeria